So, in the next theory of personality, we have the humanistic approach. And the
fundamental assumption of the humanistic approach personality is that people
are striving to be the best person they can be. That is, self-actualizing, so
you may recall from lesson 11, when we talked about Abraham Maslow's hierarchy
of needs. And at the peak of that need hierarchy was self-actualization. And
it's just that, when people are striving to be the best person they can be. Now
self-actualizing people are very rare, doesn't happen very often, but they do
seem to have some qualities, a lot of qualities actually. Some of them are for
instance, they tend to have a purpose and calling in their work. They tend to
be very simple and natural in their interactions. And in their work, they also
tend to be creative and fulfilled. Now self-actualization only happens however,
once the lower level needs are met. So first the physiological, then the
safety, and the belongingness needs have to be met before someone can attain
self-actualization.